hey guys today we're gonna be doing a
gear closet tour but unfortunately it's
a little bit messy right now before I
show you guys everything that I have in
here and how I have it organized I just
want to say a huge thank you to
CleanMyMac for sponsoring this video
I haven't using CleanMyMac for so long
it's one of the best apps ever for
clearing up storage on your Mac so while
I tell you about that in the other room
I'm gonna clean up here what do I wish I
had to Justine's in real life
I also wish I had a clean my Mac app for
my life but I don't okay let's do this
time to clean my Mac I'm super excited
to see what this is gonna be able to
clean off of my new Mac Pro obviously it
is a new computer so I can't really
imagine how much stuff I have hidden on
here that needs to be deleted a lot of
times also my older computers when I use
CleanMyMac it finds all these massive
large files that I've completely forgot
about what's great about this though is
it will find those old files it'll find
unused apps it'll find old archive
things that you've definitely forgot
about it'll bring them all to the
forefront here in the app so first if we
go up here to clean my Mac you guys can
see I just emptied my trash so
thankfully I have nothing in there now
I'm working on a really big project so I
need to have as much space as possible
so I'm gonna see if I can free up any of
this space so when I click that that
opens up clean my Mac and it
automatically does a smart scan of my
system so they are saying I can delete
three gigs three tasks so let's run
these so right now it's cleaning up the
system junk three gigs gone now we're
running our maintenance script done
flush DNS cache free ups and RAM yeah
definitely need to forget some of that
384 gigs of RAM that I have on this
machine definitely necessary and there
it is we cleared three gigs we've had no
potential threats for malware obviously
and two tasks were performed see what
else we could do
it's three women okay so this is where
we can actually see what's taking up the
most space so there's probably some
things in here that I can delete so many
color tests I can give me eight gigs
back I've already saved that somewhere
else this cool is I can go through and
just delete whatever I don't want if I
probably don't have that many old files
and sis computers only a few weeks old
see there's all the files from the red
camera which are taking up a lot of
space
there's malware removal privacy it's
like remove your browsing history
oh there's optimization as well so let's
view all 17 items so this will manage
what automatically opens up when you log
in I feel like I'm into all of those
things I've got an uninstaller which is
great easy to uninstall apps updater oh
it looks like this needs updated I'll
put a link in the description if you
guys wanna check out CleanMyMac and now
let's head back into the gear closet and
see if Justine is done cleaning yet I'm
just seeing this as weird
come on in friends here it is we're
gonna start on the side and then we'll
kind of work our way around but this is
sort of like the main center piece of
everything because these are most of the
things that I use most often I guess you
could say everything is pretty nicely
labeled so there's a bunch of Nintendo
switch accessories there's some Nintendo
switches obviously that are custom ones
that I don't use on a daily basis but at
least I know where everything is
some of these things also are labeled as
videos that I plan on shooting so this
is one of the Sega Genesis minis I'm so
hyped about this that gaming accessories
we've got some old-school déjenos we've
got one of the old PlayStation
accessories got a PlayStation VR up here
Xboxes Xbox accessories so I collect a
lot of the limited edition Xbox
controllers you know can't ever actually
use them all collector Porter call it
what you will this is just a few little
decorations this is I remember the video
from that idea of Best Buy I did a print
test the printer Oh looking for paper
who's that Wally a little 3d printed
Maddy can you believe it this is kind of
going into the drone world over here so
I've got a bunch of drone cases more
miscellaneous drone pieces you guys have
seen me review a lot of these and I
don't ever really get rid of them
because a lot of times I'd like to be
able to resort back to them so that I
can use them for comparison to newer
drones so I've got all of those here
labeled we've got the pneumatic two
drones this is mislabeled this should
say Polaroid but I haven't got a chance
to change it we have more cameras here
camera cases camera lenses which usually
they do have another home but they're
here for now so I don't know we've got
old MacBook Chargers we've got
accessories for my TV we got Microsoft
Surface accessories camera straps insta
360 they have so many cameras and so
many accessories that it needed it's
entire bin new GoPro old GoPro mobile
tripods tripods attachments and a lot of
these are really full so this is the
mobile tripod section this is everything
that has to do with like mobile tripods
we've got actual tripods we've got some
attachments there's also a whole nother
section here more tripods these are for
bigger boys problems once you take
something out give it a little shake
good enough I don't really ever use
GoPro anymore but I do like to have them
for obviously all of the accessories
because these work on a lot of different
cameras so there's always nice to have
here's some more DJI stuff and got the
Ronin SC the new Mavic is this like my
little charging station it's really it's
not that great but it gets the job done
when I have a lot of things charging I
will just kind of set everything up here
this is usually what you would use for
laundry if you're using this closet for
clothes but I use this for extra bags
these are some of my Apple badges
these are some other laptops that have
either been reviewed or need to be
reviewed that are not Mac non-apple some
of this stuff is just old boxes that I
haven't gotten rid of this is where I
usually put tripods laptop cases
keyboards and always needing different
keyboard setups depending upon which
computer I'm using we've got a bunch of
different things up here this is some of
the Apple boxes that I have got headsets
more headsets those are usually for like
VR it's like we have more keyboards up
here we have some more Apple stuff
that's actually my really old Mac books
friend we got lights a little small
camera lights and no controls so you're
not sitting down I would suggest thing
down for this one because it's so
exciting first two drawers this is
almost all USB chargers there's also
some SIM card ejectors here does anybody
need an apple charging brick I've got so
many piece because I always end up using
the bigger bricks more adapters more
dongles some of these things aren't
entirely labeled correctly I'm just kind
of the throwing things sort of back in
the general area that they should be in
over here it's a little messy but these
are a bunch of pins are selecting
Fortnite pins from all of the events
from like three things like that
it's an old Apple logo little patch I
was gonna put it on my bag that I never
did lots of it
or pins camera can't pin this used to be
a system that I had of dead and not dead
batteries but clearly it's not working
out because there's just dead ones
there's just a lot of random things
here's the original Apple watch I mean
it actually says Apple watch on the back
of it honestly it's just a bunch of
freaking cables but the MOL label though
USB a cheese PC micro USB mic oh okay
how do we get the point this is the
drawer that I love this is the phone
drawer we have got a lot of phones here
obviously a lot of iPhones but we have a
lot of the Android phones as well and I
don't like to get rid of them because I
do need them sometimes for reviews in
comparison to other phones it's just a
drawer of phones oh we hit Apple watch
and this is a holy Apple watch bands
we've got old generations of Apple
watches shattered Apple watches it's a
really sad little place over here forget
some older cameras like this Google one
which I never really don't have using
very much the old Samsung 360 Oh webcams
hello I also have a place for my Kindle
and that's where it stays so mice
pencils this says Apple pencils but
there's not a single Apple pencil in
here this is the audio section we've got
wireless packs here you're more wireless
here other just shotgun mics HDMI cables
power adapters oh we have hit the iPhone
an on iphone case says most of these are
iPhone cases but
not really sure what all this is it's
kind of just a bunch of like batteries I
did used to keep my lenses in here but I
only have a few in there now battery
chargers and D filters you know but good
whatsoever here looks like yeah this
HDMI that's no I'm not gonna ever need
an HDMI cable to that wall I guess
that's it that's all of those now let's
take a look on the other side it's less
exciting I've had a bunch of tech and
travel bags backpacks tons of backpacks
because I basically am always on the go
so there's a backpack for every
situation this is just a bunch of stuff
not a fan we have ammo with hard drives
boxes that are empty
oops that's like it I mean it's usually
pretty messy because we're always doing
back-to-back shoots I'm always traveling
so just kind of come in here and throw
stuff around but I do like when it's
nice and organized so if there's
anything that we ever need to find we
know exactly where it is this office was
organized by professional organizers and
I have definitely professionally messed
it up so a huge thank you though to them
because they've done such a great job I
showed you guys a video before of how
they did completely redo my entire house
you guys haven't seen that video be sure
to link it below but it's so amazing
anyway that's it a huge thank you to
clean my Macra sponsoring this video and
I really do feel like in both scenarios
when you do have a clean Mac or a clean
office or a clean workspace like you
just feel so relieved I'll see you guys
in my next video don't forget to Like
subscribe and comment and do all of
those things I'll see you later bye
[Music]
you